alain robbe grillet j'ai jamais entendu
dire que vous étiez réactionnaire mais
lorsqu'on faisait quand même posé la
question sait jamais non enfin je ne
crois pas mais enfin vous savez un
réactionnaire
j'en connais peu qui disent comme droits
qu'ils aient enfin donc on peut
difficilement demander à quelqu'un
quelqu'un paye ou pas toutes façons je
me sens un peu le petit garçon dans ce
débat parce que trois amis sont des
penseurs ils ont inscrit chacun un ou
des livres qui met en cause hrinova
paris dow jones la socialisation
justement je vous demande un peu ce que
je fais là parce que le mien c'est un
test roman et c'est pas du tout pensé
entre ben oui mais pas libres de penser
yahia il n'y a pas ni pensée ex cathedra
n'y pensaient prêter à des modèles non
c'est pas un genre de modestie parce que
c'est une région lui rendu de revenus
mais il n'empêche la robe grillet que
vous êtes considéré ce milieu ce 2e 3e
tiers du xxème siècle comme celui qui a
révolutionné le roman c'est à dire vous
avez révolutionner une certaine forme
romanesque et certains même pense que
votre apport au cinéma est considérable
alors donc vous êtes non pas un
réactionnaire mais plutôt un
révolutionnaire ne serait ce que dans
les formes dans le dans l'éclatement du
récit enfin je pars prendre en compte
vous êtes compte neuf wagons temps très
bien sûr il a réagi contre une forme si
les mecs existe on peut on peut définir
n'importe quoi comme réaction par
rapport à une action vous avez dit ce
qu'il fallait faire c'était pas de la
sociologie mais la biologie justement je
suis de formation biologique et pas
sociologique j'ai fait des études
uniquement de biologie mathématiques et
actions et réactions
évidemment on prend toujours pour
soutenir la réaction la réaction du
corps contre l'invasion des virus et ses
acteurs bon ce sont des métaphores
on sait où ça peut mener je sais marly
ceux ci effectivement simon a pu faire
de moi un certain porte parole ou et
demanda d'une révolution en littérature
c'est parce que effectivement je me suis
opposé à la reproduction
non pas production l'espèce est nommé à
l'héritage à l'héritage considéré comme
un modèle et je n'ai jamais dit qu'il
fallait arrêter de lire balzac
j'ai dit simplement qu'il fallait savoir
que c'était un écrivain du 19e siècle et
que nous étions au 20e et que si balzac
vivait aujourd'hui il n'écrirait pas
comme il écrivait en 1850 et j'ai réagi
contre la critique littéraire en place
qui à ce moment là était beaucoup plus
que maintenant du côté de cette majorité
silencieuse j'ai réagi contre les dogmes
de cette critique c'est-à-dire contre
une critique qui est imposé comme forme
littéraire du roman pour toujours par
une espèce de justice de droit divin
une forme qui était très récente et qui
était celle qui avait vu son apogée au
moment du triomphe de la société brian
croyez vous qu'elle imposait à elle
imposée et l'imposer elle disait
peut-être où il écrivait s'est jusqu'ici
ce que nous avons vu ou lu de mieux non
elle ne vais pas les gens et elle l'a
fait au nom de du mot roman c'est à dire
que sous la plume de ce genre de
l'époque c'est d'ailleurs très gentille
et émile henriot qui était robert kemp
qui était qui et d'autres encore qui a
fait les grandes critiques dans les
régies les red shoes et des grands
journaux et des reins il y avait une
espèce de définition normative du roman
n'est ce pas il n'y a pas de personnages
dans vos livres
tong se sont clairement liés j'avais
définition du du roman tel qu'il devait
être pour toujours manger se rejettent
les aliments à cette époque là c'est le
roman n'a pas été fait une fois pour
toutes le roman ne peut exister que s'il
change mais semble hommes restent unis
ne peut exister
non pas que comme héritage mais que s'il
est en mouvement
mais c'est seulement le mouvement des
choses qui les concerne tous pensé que
les romands michel roy sont de type
balzacien baril et ses fruits
est ce que vous lisez je sais pas ce que
vous misez des romantiques balzacien nom
bien c'est à dire que bon je suis si
vous voulez membres d'une d'un jury
littéraire
par conséquent je reçois tous les ans
tous les romans qui paraissent en france
et je les feuillette un peu tous
en plus je suis lecteur dans une maison
d'édition c'est ce qui fait que je lis
en plus toute la littérature qui n'est
pas imprimé celle qui est en train de se
faire donc j'ai une très bonne vue de la
littérature en général je suis le mieux
placé et effectivement il y a encore
aujourd'hui toute une une une catégorie
d'écrivains de lecteurs de critiques qui
veut absolument maintenir désespérément
les choses comme ça oui mais là j'ai
même chose qui est un petit peu
inquiétant c'est que le nouveau roman
vous êtes combien que nous on en trouve
iata lors que les rebels à siens il y en
a toujours des centaines par an et c'est
ce que j'ai dit que cette marque que ces
réactionnaires et et la majorité robbe
grillet je crois que par exemple vous
citiez millauriaux tout à l'heure
c'était un homme charmant et très
bientôt l'interview c'était amusant de
la zac des mois c'était un homme
c'était un homme extrêmement curieux non
seulement de son temps mais de de la
littérature curieux de ce qui existe est
curieux de ce qui pouvait exister
c'était charmant en plus il me dit une
fois vous avez vu ce que j'ai écrit sur
saint john perse
j'ai rien compris mais j'ai fait un
effort tout arrêt de choses sinon il le
faisait il le faire moi email il m'avait
dit après la jalousie vous avez vu un
je vous ai quand même fait six colonnes
elles sont idiotes peut-être mais ça
pourrait bien
tellement décriée ces tolérances mis de
l'avant tellement de critiques qui
prétendent incarner d'été lee jones ya
et quand nous publions un roman ils ne
font pas d'efforts ils ne disent même
pas ils n'en parlent pas ils viennent
pas nous dire voilà regarder ce que j'ai
fait sur votre mans et millauriaux le
faisais c'était un vrai libéral lui
alors que les autres et c'est là d'un
des traduire dans une sorte de
terrorisme d'électrons ceux qui ne sont
pas dans une certaine lit on essaie de
les mettre aux oubliettes pouvez
toujours nous qui ne serait jamais de
mes romans alors parce que je suis ce
que je suis que pouvait-on reproché à
rioz je vous le dire très exactement
c'est de n'avoir pas lu tout ce qui se
passait au xxème siècle c'est à dire que
henriot connaissait très bien la
littérature du siège dernier mais quand
il a découvert le nouveau romain on
s'est aperçu du même fou il n'avait
jamais lu niveau merde et johnny kafka
croyait mais woodside a dit il a dit oui
par un espoir à l'ong en haut je vais
jouer un petit peu chez lui envieraient
un jour ma correspondance de la tête
avec émile riou s intéressant
mais les livres de l'est peut-être vous
écrivez nous paraît cependant ce comme
vous écrivez vos romans
j'écris à la main très soigneusement je
vais jouer un petit peu les murs rue
mais très rapidement alors il m'a semblé
que votre topologie une cité fantôme
roman qui est à dire qui et par
vandoeuvre ça faut reconnaître c'est pas
vendeur
comme le titre avait été un coup reçu
sur le fantôme bon alors il m'a semblé y
voir le récit vous montrer si c'est pas
vrai
le récit d'une obsession l'obsession du
cdh obsession c'est le meurtre d'une
jeune prostituée nu et cette obsession
comme toutes les obsessions les fixes
les permanents et elle se déroule dans
un lieu qui change qui est au fond des
civilisations qui se sont succédé dans
un même endroit et cette obsession est
toujours la même
au fil des civilisations oui en somme je
vais réussir à introduire très bien ce
roman dans le débat et fait que non mais
c'est ça c'était pas ça si on veut sur
vos inventions
on peut tromper on peut en donner un
autre résumé mais il sait que donner
l'autre non non on va partir sur celui
là c'est mieux non coordonnées autant
qu'on veut est là et effectivement il y
a dans il ya dans ce roman de très
nombreux thèmes qui sont empruntés à la
culture au passé ce sont les grands
thèmes culturels qui appartiennent à la
mythologie de notre société ou des
sociétés qui l'ont précédé donc bon
c'est à dire que dans dans dance est
aujourd'hui où je suis j'ai l'impression
qu effectivement comme vous dès lors du
pâtis yatuu pas si c'est beaucoup et je
sais pas ce que vous avez lu mon petit
ami je lis luge allemand en début
d'année non non non moi je alors vous mv
à une émission alors vous êtes convainc
alors qu'il veut
mais je trouvais président mais j'ai
trouvé que votre analyse je leur ai fait
enfin loin - as dignement de migrants
rien de plus ils en ont pris à même les
suivantes à dire ça alors je vous les
eaux que j'aurais aimé lui se voir
l'opinion qu'il n'y avait rien de
particulier il ya un grand mythe
fondamentale qui se trouvent dans ce
livre que vous avez que vous avez cités
qui est aussi bien le crime sexuel que
le meurtre rituel mais d'une façon
générale la défloration violente de la
vierge qui est un thème on retrouve
n'est ce pas dans toute l'antiquité
jusqu'aux roman populaire aujourd'hui
car la culture à la contre-culture salle
autre chose n'est-ce pas ce sont les
mêmes tels qui imprègne compléter une
thérapie une société est spécialement
une heure le thème est beaucoup moins le
thème du sang dans les pays du nord est
un peu différent mais il existe aussi de
façon peut-être plus sur moi à fond
leurs questions des actionnaires nord ou
le sud alors je par définition c'est la
grèce mais athènes les joueurs objets il
a répondu j'ai l'impression comme ça si
je pense à ma à ma vie d'enfant c'est à
dire à mon éducation
à ce moment où ou justement la société
ma fille m'a tenu dans son discours
n'est ce pas où j'ai reçu jeudi secours
de la société sous la forme des livres
des livres de classe en particulier
j'ai l'impression que cette société
maintenu deux discours l'un ouvert et
l'autre cacher je lisais beaucoup des
livres qui se trouvait dans la
bibliothèque mes grands-parents à brest
qui était qu'ils étaient
vous savez ces livres quand les ados
complète de victor hugo des têtes des
choses comme ça des stades des espèces
de livres qui à la fin du xixème et au
début du xxème figurer dans toutes les
bibliothèques petite bourgeoise avec des
reliure en cuir y avait en particulier
vous voyez vous voir alors alors vu
l'origine de ma famille je te dirai
fonctionnaires et des réactions alors
qu'ils n'étaient que le pauvre cher mr
big brother oui oui oui il devrait en
particulier un livre qui est fasciné qui
est l histoire de france dany martin en
huit volumes et cette histoire de france
les historiens ne la considère peut-être
pas beaucoup enfin elle est très très
romancé mais c'était vraiment
l'historien tels que tels que la société
petites bourgeoises ou moyenne
bourgeoisie ou encore restaurée comme
quelqu'un de sérieux de raisonnable de
ne pas du tout porté vers les choses pas
propre et c est y allé des gravures
c'est une révision était sidérant
absolument sidérant je vaux attitude
n'est ce pas c'est la mort de bruno
jacques bruneau à l'époque ne veulent
avoir quelque chose comme 70's 80's
n'est ce pas lors de son supplice
c'était une jeune femme splendide
quelque chose comme la comme la
naissance de vénus dans les tableaux de
la renaissance qui était attaché par un
pied entièrement nue bien entendu
attaché par un pied à la queue d'un
cheval sauvage lancés au galop et
toulouse où cette histoire franchement
si vous la connaissez était à l'avenant
c'est à dire qu avait ce que disait le
texte et ses illustrations qui n'avait
aucun rapport et qui tenait censément le
même discours qui peuvent effectivement
le même discours mais comme l'envers de
ce discours
exactement comme dans michelez qui était
même un petit peu plus en vigueur dans
l'oeuvre de michel et alors c'est
beaucoup plus ouvert n'est ce pas il ya
second fait lire aux enfants et un
mondial à l'histoire de france
et puis à l'orgue à la sorcière va qui
est un livre où les obsessions sexuelles
de museler ou en particulier le sens de
la femme
l'obsession du sang de la femme apparaît
d'espagne de façon extraordinaire qui
son environnement lyrique et
secondairement et quand
omischl et ce s'apitoie sur les malheurs
de cette jeune sorcière la sorcière pour
michelin c'est une cover girl c'est pas
du tout une vieille femme 2 c'est
vraiment elle a exactement les
caractéristiques d'un cover girl comme
comme comme justin comme comme toutes
les héroïnes du même genre et je vis mal
bien je bouge bien la grille de
l'ancienne enfin la femme sur l'air et
c'est d'ailleurs là c'est là ce n'est
pas vraiment bon on en lien aux jeunes
filles assassinées au des deux lauréats
leur somme se pince dans cette société
qui est la mienne mais mais plutôt vu à
l'envers oui mais pourquoi y at-il
toujours leur finalement n'est un peu
d'y répondre enfin pourquoi y at-il dans
tous vos six d'entre eux les derniers
films et dans ce roman toujours donc des
jeunes filles très jeunes toujours nu
toujours avec un ciseau dans le coeur
fouetter et enfin ce slogan libérez la
fois jeune et qui se retrouvent
je verrai j'ai d'ailleurs demandé roger
kane qui nous passe un petit extrait de
votre film glissement progressif c'est
une scène qui va beaucoup plus loin
parce que c'est une scène à la fois
gastronomique et érotique c'est une
scène d'ailleurs cassé beaucoup de
scandales dont beaucoup parlé à l'époque
nous peut parler
je serais ravi que nous comme entier
justement un nom à ce que charrie avec
cette scène parce que la wii va alors
voyez le thème des oeufs de toute façon
il est aussi êtes vous n'allez pas dire
c'est moi qui les ai inventées il est
chez george pataki en particulier alors
oui c'est une
c'est une seule que j'ai amassé vous
avez deux cantons à faire un film il ya
des choses qu'on aime et des choses
qu'on aime pas je pouvais crainte soyez
tombé par action alors et j'adore les
puissants et c'est alléchant 10,8 alors
le nord et la manche où elle avait
brillé sérieusement qu'est ce que vous
expliquez nous
alors oui il est très facile d'expliquer
un ex qu'ils soient liés au film si on a
écrit un ouvrage de pensée qui devient
extrêmement difficile d'expliquer vous
montrer un morceau de sel comme ça à des
spectateurs qui n'ont pas vu le film
pour la plupart n'est ce pas ce film a
été vu par métaux de cent mille trois
cent mille personnes en france à l'heure
actuelle cet extrait là-bas être vu par
je sais pas moi 10 millions on a
beaucoup parlé par conséquent tout cas
c'est toujours toi rescousse et c'est
sans forcément ce film comme tous les
titres à vous mais pas du tout une
succession d'image skis qui viennent
l'une après l'autre à titre décoratif et
dont on peut parler séparément ce film
est une structure
c'est à dire que cette organisation
était super c de sirop de framboise
c'est parfaitement c'était à s'imposer
bien entendu nous sur l'écran de
contrôle en noir et blanc les bleus
j'allais vous n 2 dans le sens où il y
avait beaucoup plus que ça que j'étais
bon alors un des thèmes vous venez de
voir apparaître la 2d thème du film
vision le thème coupant et le thème
visqueux levis que c'est le sait le
blanc d'oeuf n'est ce pas qui qui qui
glisse l'église et le guen coupant vous
l'avez vu au cinespace et là c'est la
bouteille gastriques mais est ce que ce
qui m'importe dans un bâtiment comme
celui là ça n'est pas du tout
vous voyez la société répressive me
passionne caresse à dans quel monde
vivons nous assaillent et chocolat
l'estrie vais les finir
bon hé hé hé ce titre glissement
progressif indique bien justement la
structure du film il se trouve que
quelquefois un titre peut sembler un peu
raccrocheurs comme le glissement ou
moins comme topologie mais pour moi ce
sont toujours des titres qui donne une
espèce de schéma structurel du film il y
a au départ du film un certain nombre de
substances ou d'objets et des
glissements de sens de l'un à l'autre
et pourquoi les alors histoire de noms
mais je vous promets des nations bien
n'hésite pas à moi de vous poser une
question pourquoi parler alors plongé
dans le coma
maintenant je te réponds parce
qu'effectivement ils sont un genre de
substituts de ce à quoi ça vous a fait
penser à bon alors
rami on est en émoi qu'il fallait
s'intéresser aux sciences biologiques
mais voilà l'homme de la matière c'est
la naissance de l'homme n'est pas senti
ça oui un peu comme le chou fleur
légumes cosmique d'elle alors le
chou-fleur j'ai l'accord bon alors on
est sérieux on voulait dire quelque
chose est ce que ce n'est pas possible
de parler d'un baraquement de films
comme ça alors je serai content
j'aimerais nous jouerons du chômage
n'est ce pas mais enfin et ce film est
justement et c'est par hasard car je
sais pas où j'allais passer un fragment
2010 à contribuer davantage au logis
mais se trouve être une adaptation très
libre de la sorcière
alors si elle n'est pas libre il
n'aurait toutes les bobines du film non
mais je crois qu'il doit courir
pierre chaunu la cheville non non non
non écouter n'empêche je dis que ce
texte ils n'ont pas fait exprès temps
jouer simplement dire que lice marc nous
a raconté tout à l'heure vers prier
surface son enfance et sur le cette
histoire de martin m'a finalement si
vous voulez peut-être aider à comprendre
la topologie topologie d'une cité
fantôme
c'est cette espèce de dix ans et cette
constance d'un thème finalement ils
descendent dans le temps un thème
obsessionnel possède le mien pourquoi
pas qui est ce la société où je vis en
tout cas également que jeux rétro que
j'ai retrouvé avec une telle assistance
maintenant je voudrais parler quand même
de ce phénomène il reste une minute bon
2 bon ça c'est un petit peu ça a été un
petit peu comme ça dans le moment d'en
débattre
ce qui fait qu'il a été question de
sexualité il y a quand même encore à
l'heure actuelle et la majorité est avec
vous pour ça une espèce de censure et
vous avez raison elle n'est pas
seulement à droite
elle est à droite elle est à gauche vous
avez vu ces images là ces images-là ont
provoqué un effet comique c'est à dire
que les il y a eu des rires dans la
salle où de la part d'eads et des
spectateurs excepté le rire comme vous
savez est une des ligues est bon et
effectivement dans la société
alors il ya encore des progrès à faire
cher michel droit ça va être terrible
pour vous mais à l'heure actuelle c'est
vrai que la société encore de votre côté
les navires qu'elle réprime le sexe il
réprime le sexe parce que parce que la
société ri quand on lui a déversé des
jeux sur le corps d'une femme
oui bon dans tous les cas au tour à quel
rythme semblant simplement que la
prochaine fois je jure elle boit
produits frais manger des biens mais
finalement le vous parlez des seuls qui
a parlé de l'avenir finalement c'est
pauwels